[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to Google Cloud
next 22 take your career to the next
level with a Google Cloud certification
my name is Magda and I'm joined today by
me now we are really delighted to
present this content to you
let's take a look at our agenda for
today first let's review the Google
Cloud skills landscape then let's have a
look at the Google Cloud credentials and
certifications specifically
then we are going to hear from me now
and learn all about tips from the expert
about certification Readiness and then
finally we will wrap up with some
special offers so let's get started with
the overview of Google Cloud skills
you know that 85 of businesses will
adopt a cloud first principle by 2025.
moreover 80 percent of it leaders feel
that they have a lack of skills and
knowledge among their employees
meanwhile the future of work is in the
cloud
so we encourage you to demonstrate your
Cloud knowledge and stay ahead of the
curve with Google Cloud credentials and
certifications
you can literally stand out with Google
Cloud certification
an interesting data point 87 percent of
hiring managers value hands-on
experience and certifications over a
University degree when evaluating
candidates
and 82 percent of hiring managers say
that cloud certifications make a
candidate more attractive
and we are really delighted to review
the impact of our Google Cloud
certification program
so our candidates say 78 of them feel
more confident in professional future
82 percent can improve Cloud scale
competency to recruiters
83 percent feel that their resume is
more attractive and then finally 85
percent feel more confident in Cloud
skills
our learning options here at Google
Cloud support you on your certification
journey and Beyond
so you can start with learning
then um definitely engage in practice
and hands-on experience we have all
kinds of certification Readiness with
skill badges as Milestones on your
journey for role bails based
certifications finally you can certify
and then all the options to keep your
learning going and your skills current
Beyond certifications
with regards to building your Cloud
skills our catalog caters to all
learning styles with over 700 different
pieces of learning content delivered in
multiple formats
so you can choose from on-demand
training
Hands-On learning with blogs and quests
you can attend in-person training or
engage in game 5 learning
so now let's take a look at the Google
Cloud credentials and certifications
we have different levels of credentials
so upon completion of your learning your
training you are likely to receive a
completion badge
then when you engage in hands-on
experience and complete a number of
quests with a final assessment challenge
lab you will earn your skill badge and
then finally our Google Cloud certified
program
um that helps you validate your skills
and knowledge at this next level of
proficiency
so taking a look at our Google Cloud
certifications portfolio you'll notice a
variety of exams our fundamental level
exams exam with the cloud digital leader
the associate Cloud engineer
and then the remaining exams job role
specific at the professional level
so you might wonder which Google Cloud
certification is right for me where
should I begin
so we hope you'll find this resource
helpful it's also available on our
website
what is the profile of the candidate for
each of the exam tiers
and then what is the assessment area for
each of the exams whether that's the
cloud digital leader more for the
business audience who are really
interested in learning the language of
cloud cloud engineer for technical
individuals who work Hands-On with the
clouds to deploy and configure in manage
Cloud Solutions and then finally our
professional level exams for experienced
technical professionals
we also have this
um available for you in the sketchnel
format so if you wonder which Google
Cloud certification is right for me this
resource might be very helpful for you
personally to take you on the Journey of
selecting where do I begin so you'll
find this as a resource attached to this
session as well and we hope you enjoy it
so what are some of the benefits of
certifications that you will enjoy
first distinguish yourself with a Google
Cloud certified badge NIH certificate
for our professional level exams receive
exclusive Google Cloud certified
merchandise and then for all exams
you'll also receive digital assets
you can Network and exchange ideas in
the Google Cloud certified community and
then finally special recognition at
select events
so if you're ready to get started we
invite you to invest in Google Cloud
credentials and certifications today
and I'm really delighted now to welcome
me now and we are going to hear from her
all things around certification
Readiness and the tips from
um from her as as the expert welcome me
now
thank you so much Magda for having me
I'm super happy to share the tips and
the tricks to prepare for certification
thank you so much
thank you so the first question me now
please tell us a little bit about your
role here at Google cloud and your
experience with helping candidates
prepare for certification exams
sure so I joined Google Cloud almost
five years back as a technical trainer
and my specialization is data and
machine learning now as a trainer I
basically deliver variety of courses
which comes under data and machine
learning and
um typically all my participants ask me
a question hey Miguel can you tell us
how can we prepare for certification so
that is something which I always find
exciting in each and every class
recently I have also taken over as a
training manager for Japan and Asia
Pacific and certifications is still a
Prime Focus area for me so let me share
some of the things which really help
people in getting certified first and
most important thing anyone who is
preparing for certification needs to
really think from that roles perspective
for example I want to appear for
professional data engineering
engineering exam and the role involved
here is data engineer now I really need
to start thinking like a data engineer
in order to understand the questions and
in order to come to a correct solution
now second most important thing
there is no one-to-one relationship
between a particular course and Google
Cloud certification this is a big myth I
may say so everyone who is preparing for
Certification need to really complete an
exhaustive study of Google cloud with
respect to theoretical concept with
respect to Hands-On implementation and
the reference architectures or reference
Solutions which are shared on
cloud.google.com once the candidate or
once the participant has exhaustive
knowledge or thorough understanding
about the technology which is working
behind scene of Google Cloud it will be
a really simple thing to clear the
certification so let me start about how
one can initiate this particular process
now let us consider we are preparing for
professional data engineering exam now
there is a certification page for the
this particular certification and this
page is going to be our always to be
referred kind of documentation now the
first thing that I always recommend
participants to go through the exam
objectives these objectives necessarily
gives us idea about the assessment
criterias and how we should actually
understand the assessment parameters for
example uh in data engineering exam
there is one objective which is called
as building storage the storage solution
for the problem statement now when we
start reading about this particular
objective
um we find some topics given like okay
making yourself you know familiar with
All Storage Technologies which are
available on Google Cloud then
understanding the various features which
are being offered by these Technologies
and then actually deciding
which situation which technology can be
used and something like that now once we
start going through these objectives
they've actually help us in analyzing
and understanding okay what is the
expectation over here and how can we
actually start coming to a conclusion so
first and most important Point
um go to your exam guide and start
reading through the exam objectives
second most important thing in your exam
guide it is also mentioned that what all
activities what all courses labs are to
be completed as a part of preparation I
sincerely request everyone to complete
all those activities to gain full
confidence about your preparedness for
the examination now typically a couple
of courses are mentioned there and you
can always complete those courses by
attending a virtual instructor-led class
or you may go to our on-demand portals
and you can go through those courses
then comes most important Point
implementing learned theoretical
Concepts in a Hands-On lab now we always
recommend completing as many Labs
possible from our
on-demand portals like say skills boost
where 700 plus labs are available and
they cover pretty much everything
required once we complete all these
Hands-On activities we actually feel
pretty well confident about the
preparedness and then I also recommend
people start going through documentation
documentation explain us the magic
working behind Google cloud and once we
start going through documentation we
actually start understanding certain
Concepts which are not clear so far in
this journey uh along with the
documentation going through the solution
Pages how to's and tutorials is another
important aspect of Readiness or
preparedness I will say uh Solutions
give us clarity about okay certain
companies use these products and this is
how their use case actually looks like
okay and that starts expanding our
Horizons about the things that we are
learning and then
while you are doing all these things
there is also practice exam available
which is static in nature but it gives
us pretty fair idea about our
preparedness about the examination
um I typically take this sample exam at
least twice during my study tour and
that helped me in understanding which
areas still need study and still need
some deep dive to be done so pretty
simple process uh if you follow all
these steps it will be really simple and
enjoyable Journey for all of you but
trust me on that so I think that is all
which I would like to share here as main
tips
super helpful thank you so much Minal
and any other things you'd like to share
with our candidates who are considering
any certification
yes for sure so first most important
thing
um don't think getting certified is a
super tough job actually it is a very
simple activity if you follow a
particular discipline I always recommend
my participants to
um devote at least one hour to one hour
30 minutes each day for next four weeks
to six weeks duration and I I request
them to follow all the study material
which I mentioned a few minutes back uh
really sincerely a lot of reading a lot
of Hands-On practice gives us a very
good confidence and we can certainly
clear uh the certification in the given
duration okay and most important thing
please please please remember there is
no one-to-one mapping between a course
and a certification Google Cloud
certifications always check a
candidate's knowledge on exhaustive
level on thorough understanding level so
I wish all of you a very best love best
of luck and you know go ahead achieve
your certification share it on LinkedIn
and I will give you a thumbs up that's
it thank you
that's wonderful thank you again me now
for all the great tips and and wisdom
and knowledge really a pleasure
so uh with that uh it's time for us to
wrap up and I have an exciting uh offer
to share with you for anyone who'd like
to continue your Cloud Learning Journey
First Complete hashtag Cloud Google
Cloud challenges today and you can find
all the information about this challenge
or in our developer Zone innovators Hive
website for our new Learners we invite
you to begin your 30 days no cost
training trial so you can access all the
great materials we've talked about here
at no cost so visit Cloud skillsboost
dot Google subscriptions
and then finally uh very excited uh for
this announcement here at
um Cloud next start your Google Cloud
skills boost annual subscription with a
variety of really exciting benefits
around this so I strongly encourage
everyone to consider and and take a look
at this new offer and it's also
available under
cloudskillsboost.google slash
subscription so
whichever option is best for you please
take action now engage there's so much
opportunity around learning and earning
your credentials and certifications and
we are really wishing you all the best
around this journey
and with that a big thank you to all of
you for joining us today uh wishing you
a very enjoyable Google Cloud next 22.
thank you me now again and again
everyone take care and it's been
wonderful to share this content with you
bye
foreign